[Music]  former patriots o lineman said that he  purposely got into a car crash so that  he had an excuse for being late to a  patriots practice rich orenberger told a  story on his radio show about how he  overslept his rookie year and knew he'd  be late to a meeting with bill belichick  and the team rich knew he's either on  time or he's cut from the team for being  late he said in a moment of quick  thinking he looked to the car in front  of him and said to himself that he's  gonna hit the car because it's better to  pay off the insurance and embarrass  himself from being late in front of the  team and bill turns out bill belichick's  assistant was still pissed that he was  asleep